we don't hear about your relationships I
know you were in a relationship for like
three years right but you're pretty like
we don't see you walking around with
anyone you keep this all very low-key
you're off the television life I'm not a
fan of celebrity you're not a part of
the the yeah like I don't see you on a
daily now I don't know not a big fan of
celebrity how do you keep it all so
quiet how do you fly on the radar where
do you meet people I'm lucky I I
gravitate towards real people in life I
meet women
I have everywhere that's the thing is
like I think you'll ever be married I'm
not opposed to it but it's not gonna
happen I'm married to it maybe you'll
calm down with the work and you'll uh I
don't know I can only know where I am
now in life and that's what I've learned
to enjoy appo and when you meet a woman
you you you you lay out your philosophy
say listen I'm into I'm open to love
which is what we should all do how it is
when we meet people we should tell you
who we are be honest you know why you
should have the person love you or hate
you for who you are not for who you
portray yourself to be how many people
go into a relationship like a used car
salesman yes bullshitting about who they
are what maybe I love long walks on the
beach yes I love I love adventure you
don't like a rancher you hate whitewater
rafting you hate adventure you hate oh
you leaving the house be honest say I
like sitting on the couch and watching
too much TV and I'm a slob and then if
somebody goes I love that and they're
being honest you have now found true
love but what happens with people as you
go I'm Tom Cruise I like hanging on the
side of planes and living a good life
right and then two years in the love
starts fading that the infatuation
starts fading and then the person goes
do you want to go outside and you look
we're we're always going outside and
they're like well you never want to go
outside and then you like Norma and then
it's like you changed you changed like
no you didn't change you just learn on
and really our guys are trained to be
salesmen we're like we're trying to
seduce all the time so oh I love yes
going to tennis match but you can seduce
without being dishonest about who you
are and that's who you are you are what
I'm trying honest all the time that's
what I'm trying to be look at you now
listen to this that is true romance when
you lose the naivete of like you just
enjoy it
all that's why I'm an advocate is living
together before you get married I'm a
big advocate for not living together
ever even if you're married
really I think let me hear this I think
one of the biggest reasons people get
divorced and relationships break up is
because of this cohabiting [ __ ] that
we've come to believe is the way
relationships are supposed to be I'm
gonna recommend a relationship with
Robin Quivers live with anybody that's
good for you you cannot tell me that
everyone was designed to hide every same
way not ever and that's what I'm saying
our intimacy can wail I wonder I don't
know beautiful